Efe o sabah dedesinin bahçesinde iki şeyi aynı anda gördü.
Kümeste tabuk, yumurtalarının üstünde kıpırdamadan oturuyordu.
Ahırın köşesinde kedi, yeni dolmuş yavrularını yalıyordu.
Yavru kediler daha o günden annelerine benziyordu.
Yumurtaların içinde ne olduğunuysa kimse göremiyordu.
Efe merak etti.
Biri doğuyor, öteki yumurtadan çıkıyordu.
Cevap, hayvanlarda üreme ve gelişme çeşitliliğinde saklıydı.
Efe işin başına üremeye bakmaya karar verdi.
Hayvanların çoğu eşeğili ürer.
Bir erkek üreme hücresi ve bir dişi üreme hücresi birleşir.
Erkek üreme hücresine "spam" denir.
Dişi üreme hücresine ise "yumurta" denir.
Ama bu ikisinin nerede buluştuğu her şeyi değiştirir.
Efe bahçenin alt ucundaki gölete indi.
Suyun içinde balıklar sığ kıyı boyunca yüzüyordu.
Dişi balık yumurtalarını doğrudan suya bırakır.
Erkek balık da spermlerini aynı suya bırakır.
Spermle yumurta dış ortamda, suyun içinde birleşir.
Buna "dış döllenme" denir.
Açıkta risk çoktur.
Çoğu yumurta yavruya dönüşemez.
Bu yüzden bir seferde milyonlarca yumurta bırakılır.
Kurbağalar da yumurtalarını aynı suya bırakır.
Efe göletten bahçeye geri döndü.
Kümes'teki tavuk hâlâ yumurtalarının üstündeydi.
Kuşlarda döllenme dişinin vücudunun içinde gerçekleşir.
Yılanda, kertenkelede ve kaplumbağada da böyledir.
Kedi de, atta ve keçide de döllenme içeride olur.
Buna "iç döllenme" denir.
İçeride spermle yumurtanın buluşma şansı yüksektir.
Bu yüzden yumurta sayısı çok daha azdır.
Döllenme tamamdı.
Peki yavru nasıl büyür ve doğar?
Efe aynı bahçede bunun üç ayrı yolunu gördü.
Birincisi doğurarak çoğalmaktır.
Yavru, annenin karnında gelişir ve öyle doğar.
Doğduktan sonra anne sütüyle beslenir.
Kedi, koyun, inek, yarasa, balina ve insan böyledir.
İkincisi yumurtlayarak çoğalmaktır.
Döllenme içte olur ama yavru yumurtanın içinde gelişir.
Yumurta annenin vücudunun dışındadır.
Tavuk yumurtalarının üstüne yatar ve onları ısıtır.
Buna "kuluçka" denir.
Yılan ve kaplumbağa yumurtalarını toprağa bırakıp gider.
Üçüncüsü balıklardır.
Onlarda hem döllenme hem gelişme suyun içinde olur.
Yavru bakımı kuşlarda ve memelilerde vardır.
Yumurtasını bırakıp giden canlılarda yavru bakımı yoktur.
Efe dönerken maydanozun üstünde bir tırtıl gördü.
Bazı canlıların yavruları erginlere hiç benzemez.
Tırtıl bir süre sonra kendini kozanın içine kapatır.
Kozadan çıkan artık tırtıl değil kelebektir.
Bu büyük değişime başkalaşım denir.
Kurbağa yavrusunun önce solungaçları ve kuyruğu vardır.
Efe kümese döndüğünde yumurtalardan biri çatlamıştı.
Her canlının nesnini sürdürmek için kendine özgü bir yolu vardı.